what's going on reject nation
greg and john here we just want an
excuse to use the mics today
because they're so fancy but legendary
has given us a good excuse today who
broke this news
oh hollywood reporter broke this
hollywood reporter
is talking about a godzilla versus kong
sequel is
in development right now they are
talking with the director of that movie
adam wingard about doing it and right
now it seems like they have a pretty
good idea on the horizon
and that is going to be called son of
kong now i
am very much excited about this believe
it or not
just this morning when john walked
through the living room door i started
talking about godzilla vs kong this
morning and why i love it so much and
how so much of it rested on even though
i've been team godzilla
the reason that movie works so well is
because of how adam winger chose to
capture
kong specifically in that film so the
idea of bringing adam wingard back and
making it
a kong family based movie that really
excites me
i don't know exactly what the plot would
be i highly doubt that this would be
inspired by
the 1930s son of kong movie i feel like
if we completely do its own thing but
what i was telling john this morning of
why
godzilla versus kong works so well that
was a rare ex
film where you're like yeah i don't
really care about the humans but the
monster stuff i really cared about and
it dawned on me
why is because all the elements of
humanity and pathos all that was given
to
the performance of kong in that film
kong
felt pretty much like a human character
who just couldn't speak
but there was so much nuance in the way
they captured him like you could tell
what he's thinking
and feeling throughout that entire film
you wouldn't enjoy that last fight so
much
unless you had some type of emotional
investment because if you look at the
other
monster movies the supporting characters
are the monsters while the humans are
the main characters and in godzilla vs
kong
kong was the main character and that's
what made it work so well and i think
adam wingard really knew how to hone
in on that i'm kind of hoping that you
don't really do any humans in this one
and you just do it mainly with kong this
time around
he said he wanted kong to be like an 80s
action hero so i think that worked out
well
that like quiet type yeah just the body
language you sympathize for him and care
for him if it is the direction of sonic
kong that works so well with the kong
storyline that we have set up here with
this install with this rendition of him
in kong skull island he's a loner his
whole family was killed off he's the
last remaining one and then in godzilla
versus kong before he goes into hollow
earth
the way they kind of trick him into
going in there is your family's in there
you have
others like you in there they kind of
trick him into it and there's that look
that he has on there
this loss almost as if he already was a
father or maybe it was just his
ancestors or maybe it was his like
parents or grandparents but there was
this quality that did kind of make you
think maybe he
did have a kid or something or maybe
there's that mournful quality of being
aware that you were removed and and
displaced so
far from your home and from where your
family would have lived
skull island seems pretty remote at
least given the uh
entryway they find in this particular
kong vs godzilla movie
but my my point being is that you start
off with kong
yeah he's like king of the island here
in on hollow earth he finds his home but
he's still alone
you know he's he still doesn't have
anyone else like him there i don't know
exactly how he would
have a son i don't know if there's some
type of genetic sex scene
yeah full-on that's actually he met up
with godzilla he's a hybrid if they
could do
a hybrid of godzilla and king kong i
mean
everybody is king caesar right there
it's king caesar from the original king
kong versus godzilla that's who that
would be
i would weirdly be down for some time
man well i felt like the part of the
best parts of godzilla vs kong was when
it went weird if there's no
other apes like or tied in apes the way
how kong is i don't know how they would
how that would happen maybe in hollow
earth he does find others like him
so it wasn't a full online when they let
him into hollow earth
maybe there is some type of you know
kong is old now because like hong kong
is pretty old
it seemed like the people in monarch
really care a lot about kong's
well-being and maybe they want to help
provide him a family
in some way definitely so they do some
type of good folks genetics scientific
give him a son yeah they can test tube
him up a son or something i mean there
are a lot of different ways to go i know
the original one they just go back to
skull island and they're like damn
there's a 17 foot tall little kong over
here and and you know
i can't imagine that they would want to
go entirely after that movie's plot
although if you look at godzilla versus
kong i mean there are certain elements
that do hearken to the original movies
yeah it's it's an interesting prospect
because part of the fun here is seeing
what they choose to remain faithful to
and what they choose to get wacky with i
personally welcome more
fantasy especially because that was one
of my favorite aspects of godzilla vs
kong is that they honed in on
the sort of ray harryhausen-esque
creature fantasy as well as the sci-fi
action stuff so yeah and the idea you
know of honing further in on kong as
a character is i think a great idea and
having a family
for kong to you know invest in and to
fight for i think would be an
interesting thing to throw in because
it's not without the realm of a
character like that you know animals and
instincts and packs and stuff
family totally figures into that and
that also gives him more reason to fight
whoever is threatening the family or
maybe kong will be needing saved by
the son of kong who knows i mean i feel
like you could actually do your own just
hollow earth movie i think that was some
of people's favorite parts
of godzilla vs kong it's like yes it was
the fight between godzilla and kong and
mechagodzilla that was the big highlight
of it but i think a lot of what really
clicked with people was actually going
into hollow earth and wanted to explore
more of that
and the fact of how so many scenes work
so well just off of the body language
and the expressions
of kong i think you can do a movie where
you really hone in
mainly on that and you don't really rely
on
human interaction because there's only
so many versus movies you could do
i mean it's like you gotta eventually
pair them up with a titan you gotta have
some action scenes in there but i think
uh what kind of surprised people was in
godzilla versus kong just how much
heart there really was in that there was
like a
real type of dramatic connective
aspect to him and so for some reason my
mind is going i want more of that mainly
more than the action more than the crazy
titan stuff and as far as like the
godzilla element i think they're still
working out
deals of how they can continue on to
have godzilla in here i believe that
part of the contract where touhou
ended i think at the end of the day kong
skull island is still the highest
grossing one
of them all kong in the in the u.s to
say the least
seems to be the favored one at least the
biggest box office draw and they go
where the money goes
you know i don't know i want godzilla to
continue on i root it for godzilla i
love godzilla
but if you wanted to do the sequel with
uh you know
son of kong or something that is mainly
just kong based on hollow earth
and with adam winger doing it that that
i'm more excited at the idea of adam
winger continuing to do a kong movie
than i would be him continue to do a
godzilla movie i just put it like that
yeah yeah i think that's a good call
there i enjoy seeing all the different
monsters show up and stuff i like the
monster verse being a thing but yeah and
for
a director of this current monster verse
to be brought back it does seem like he
is a fitting choice
because uh for various other than just
the financial success but it seems like
he was able to tap
into something that at least made up for
the losses that just
jam packing king of the monsters with
monsters
didn't help to alleviate you know so
yeah i mean it'll be interesting to see
what
also just a returning director to this
new godzilla
kong monster franchise will do it'd be
neat to see him actually be able to
build on what they did before and maybe
hopefully
try a couple things that maybe they had
to pare down on because we gotta get
this one right
and also wouldn't this be the first time
a director within the monsterverse would
be returning for a follow-up
that's pretty cool it was looking like
godzilla vs kong would be the end of
this series
and at least for right now it sort of
got like a stay of execution because of
this success so
you know i'm just excited to see what
they come up with and hopefully it
sticks a landing
of some kind i'm i'm very excited
about that i i i'm really hoping they
make this deal happen
adam winger continuing kong that gets me
jacked that really does
it really does like i said john came
through the door this morning and i just
started talking about it
and then this news came out so hell yeah
very much excited for it guys
what do you think about this news leave
your thoughts down below subscribe click
that notification bell hit that like
button we'll be sure to follow this
catch you guys soon